so joe wrote a while back when he
contracted covet uh he ended up taking
ivermectin as well as a few other drugs
that his doctor prescribed horse the
warmer
cnn there afterwards called it horse
dewormer which is nonsensical because if
you know the drug itself it's been
administered to people all over the
world all right it's not recommended
that you take it for covet but there's
human
doses that you take for regular people
cnn ran with the headline that it's
horse dewormer that joel rowling's
twinkling horses do warmer which is
incredibly disingenuous it's like saying
what they did not run with it
they marathon with it yes they iron man
with that
so
so here's what happened okay we didn't
swim with it bike with it so after that
happened joe got upset he's like guys
you're lying this is this is defamation
you're saying i'm taking horse dewarmer
it's prescribed to me by a literal
doctor you can feel however you want but
i have a rectum you can say that joe
rogan's irresponsible for taking the
drug and put on life
if i grant you all of that cnn just got
up and lied
straight up it's like it's like it's
like you drinking a glass of water and
then cnn goes like oh you're drinking
engine coolant it's like what are you
talking about it's water sitting on
myself okay that's stupid you know you
don't qualify things like that or you're
taking animal drugs you mean antibiotics
like what are you smoking okay just
because it can be applied to animals and
there's plenty of drugs that can be
doesn't mean that once a human use it
intensely they're using animal drugs
that's dumb cnn just flat out lives
why because it's part of their agenda
they see joe rogan as like some right
fit wing figure and so if they can
discredit him it works with their fan
base whatever sanji gupta who's the head
chief medical officer for cnn
went on joe rogan they had a back and
forth and joe rogan's like yo why did
your people lie i don't know why they
did it why did your people lie i don't
know they didn't lie joe yes they lied
and then he eventually after being
pushed and pushed he concedes
they shouldn't have done that they
shouldn't have called it horse dewormer
because ivormectin
is
fine
in terms of being used for people in
that human application but even watching
that interview if you really pay
attention he's so reluctant to admit it
because he's beholden to his employers
even though his chief objective as a
doctor should be to care for his
patients and public good he's still very
concerned about his job and not losing
it they're lying at your network about
people taking human drugs versus drugs
professionals calling it a horse
dewormer is not a flattering thing i get
it it's a lie it's a lie on a news
network and it's a lie that's a willing
that's that's a lie that they're
conscious of this is not a mistake yeah
they're unfavorably framing it as
veterinary medicine why would you say
that when you're talking about a drug
that's been given out to billions and
billions of people a drug that was
responsible for one of the inventors of
it making the nobel prize nobel prize in
2015. yeah yeah a drug that has been
shown to stop viral replication in vitro
you know that right why would they lie
do you the thing is we're like going so
fast like i feel like i'm missing i'm
missing you i want that's a problem that
your news network lies
well i don't think dude what did they
say they lied when they said i was
taking horse dewormers first of all it
was prescribed to me by a doctor yeah
yeah a long time
a bunch of other medications if you got
a human pill because there were people
that were taking it the veterinary
medication and i you're not obviously
you got it from a doctor so that it
shouldn't be called that won't doctors
sign an oath to do that yeah
and it's important to note this because
sometimes we always talk about
misinformation on the right trump
misinformation there's a lot of
left-wing people who also do a lot of
misinformation who absolutely lie and
you have to ask yourself when public
trust in the media is already at an
all-time low and you're saying something
that everyone knows is a lie
we know you're lying we know that you're
misrepresenting it what do you think
that does to public trust what do you
think that does for you when you come
out with a message later on that you
want us to buy into but we've just
witnessed you lie get cold on it and
continue to try lying
that's crazy statistically speaking
public trusted media is an all-time low
absolutely right now
sanji gupta goes back onto cnn and has a
conversation with don lemon
and dom and lemon doesn't double down on
the sly this [ __ ] triples down
he says no
uh sanjay i need you to admit right here
on television that horses do take this
drug and that it is used as a horse
dewarmer so it's not a lie to say i'm
like bruv are you okay in the head he he
did say something about ivermectin that
i think wasn't actually correct about
cnn and lying okay ivormectin
is a drug that is commonly used as a
horse dewormer so it is not a lie to say
that the drug is used as a horse
dewormer are you sick
who the [ __ ] raised you
but that's how these people work and
sanji gupta
turned into sanjay guber okay
and he's like you know what
yes i was wrong to go on joe rogan and
say i'm like [ __ ] you took it back
you're right i mean the fda even put out
a statement saying you know basically
reminding people it was a strange sort
of message from the fda but they said
you're not a horse you're not a cow stop
taking this stuff is essentially what
they said referring to ivermectin now i
think what what joe's point is
for humans and but not necessarily for
covet right yeah that's correct
and
watching all of this unfold is like he's
a doctor he has no spine it's not
because you are a doctor that you have a
spine it's not because you're a doctor
that you staying for think i'm getting
paid i'm just gonna shut the [ __ ] up and
that's the thing it's not because you're
anything that you are
it's not because you signed a home it
goes for doctors it goes for nurses it
goes for the goddamn police that's
supposed to serve and protect that take
an oath
it's not because you're supposed to that
you will sometimes you just don't want
to fight the fight you want to lay down
and have a nap you know what i'm having
that yeah that's why a bunch of you guys
got married and still [ __ ] somebody
else married people betray their oaths
that's why
every everybody can switch it up
everybody can switch it up i was i was
dating a doctor back in the day and this
is one of the most mind-blowing things i
learned when doctors prescribe you
medication they don't just go for what's
the best on the shelf they're often paid
to give you certain medications doctors
have these retreats
where
uh the medical industry right the
pharmaceutical industry sends its
representatives and basically gives
these doctors they can't directly give
them money but they'll give them lavish
gifts incentives yes yes it's not going
to encourage them to use certain drugs
i'm not going to give you cash but if
you thought that much i could give you a
trip right because because they get
kicked back from the hospital after a
certain amount of drugs are administered
from their company so you have to
understand these people are very much in
bed with the very same pharmaceutical
companies that are trying to give you
these vaccines or try to give you these
drugs or try to give you this
competition now this is not a conspiracy
what i'm telling you the fact that
doctors have this influence you can look
this up for yourself it's not crazy
that's how it works that's it there's
not even a doctor who's going to come in
here and say i'm wrong i dare someone
but that that's that's how it works i
see that we went on a trip together they
paid for my truck of course i was like
yes what antibiotics you want me to
swallow but that's how it works what do
you want me to inject i'm going to
cobble baby
i was bought and paid for
by the illuminati i can tell you this
myself okay
it felt great
free vacation all expenses paid for
fantastic but anyways this is why you
have people who don't trust
officials or media when it comes to
these kinds of scenarios
you foster this mistrust you foster
people looking at you sideways when you
blatantly lie to your face who here in
the right mind will trust organizations
that have already lied to them it's like
you guys coming out tomorrow and the
police officers are being like okay
negroes come into the jail cells for
your safety you think [ __ ] gonna buy
into that why because there's been a lot
of mistrust anyways um so me watching
this story
just very disappointing it's very
disappointing and there seems to be like
a real interest in what joe rogan has to
say at all time for mainstream media
so strange
he's really become that dude he's that
dude he's that guy
no he's that guy my guy yeah what do you
think about all this you know me what do
you know i don't know you like that yes
you don't mean
for that [ __ ] for what [ __ ] stash kind
of [ __ ]
i have a distrust into people
i don't trust human beings
i'm not surprised that this [ __ ] would
happen
i've seen it before
i've seen it over and over again
and that [ __ ] happened this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] turned all turning
over like a like a pancake yeah
only thing missing was maple syrup
brother you already know flip-flop
flip-flop
flip flop
yeah as
brazilian brothers were to say flippy
floppy
you know i mean i'm not i'm not
surprised by this because that first as
you said before that's how it works yeah
incentives
and he has an inceptive gupta has an
inceptive
in shutting the [ __ ] up
shut up
keep your job would you say cnn told him
to shut up and scribble
shut up and dribble yeah yeah yeah i saw
what you did there no no no no no i'm
not saying i'm not saying they did that
but i wasn't surprised if they did yeah
you know what i mean shut up and
scribble
like just shut up and just say what we
what you're told to say it's like bruh
you dropped it on that and as much as
you want to crucify joe rogan as much as
you wanna you and i you know what i hope
i hope and i wish
as a matter of fact let me put this
little
joe i'm talking to you right now joe
i'm talking to you right now
i hope you sue
oh
it's a waste of money i hope you sue
there's no way he's gonna win he got
[ __ ] you money yeah but he's not going
to win and it's a waste of money
even if you got [ __ ] you money you're
not trying to throw 30 million at some
as a lost cause oh my god not cause you
got [ __ ] you money that you just start
throwing it out the window i understand
but i know that's like what you say
but hey i just wanted to to to kind of
play this video but yeah don't gloss
over misinformation on the left side
because it exists as well but anyways
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to we want to
hear from you